arem un soir je suis rentré chez moi
j'ai allumé la télé je pensais pas
regarder la télé ce soir là je t'ai vu à
l'heure de vérité
je suis resté tout seul sur mon lit
jusqu'à la fin le téléphone sonnait je
laissais le répondeur prendre les
messages
j'ai eu souvent les larmes aux yeux
parce que je trouve que ce soir là tu as
atteint quelque chose de grand c'est à
dire qu'au delà des prises de position
politiques ou sociales
tu as été humain humanis sans doute et
hulin certainement
[Musique]
tout le monde te la dit je voulais te le
dire moi aussi je veux savoir ce que
cette cette soirée a changé dans ta vie
je te remercie fait ce qu'il méritait ce
qui est souvent c'est qu'il ya plein de
gens qui nous ont rappelés après
l'émission
j'ai reçu beaucoup de courrier j'ai pas
encore pu répondre à tous d'ailleurs
et je crois que le message de sos est un
peu mieux passé c'est vrai que pour la
première fois on a eu le temps de le
restituer la cohérence de ce qu'on peut
faire comprendre que on fait des
concerts parce qu'on aime bien la fête
mais on fait aussi de l'action concrète
de solidarité sur le terrain que c'est
vrai que des fois on apparaît un peu
comme des des agitateurs des gens qui
embête parce qu'ils viennent dénoncer
d'une telle agression telles
déclarations racistes mais que c'est pas
simplement pour le plaisir de dénoncer
c'est parce qu'on a un espoir un espèce
de rêve comme disait martin luther king
c'est que demain tous ceux qui sont
venus ici pour travailler tous leurs
enfants qui sont nés quelle que soit
leur origine
et puis se sentir bien en france et que
les autres puissent bien les accueillir
c'est bon c'est ce qui va changer mon
avis est ce que tu as eu le sentiment
d'être définitivement admis dans la dans
la communauté française maintenu comme
un partisan mais comme comme un
communiste comme on dit que cassin est
un humaniste
aujourd'hui oui cassin et tous ceux qui
après la guerre on dise on dit plus
jamais ça plus jamais la barbarie nazie
qui ont fait la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme
je crois qu'ils ont légué un héritage
qu'il faut faire vivre bon ce que ça a
changé c'est que les gens attendent
encore plus de nous et puis je crois
qu'un poids coq avant peut-être oui
parce que
l'espérance et il est encore la barre
est plus haute
bon puis je crois qu'il faut être quand
même modeste dans la réussite c'est vrai
que bon on est peut-être mieux reçus
mais pour changer les choses sur le
terrain il faudra du temps l'intégration
la tolérance changer les mentalités
ça prendra du temps en même temps il
faut aller vite on va partir 92 c'est
l'europe
ouais ça veut dire que le combat lui le
seulement en france mais oui on peut
plus imaginer qu'on va vivre dans notre
hexagone juste entre nous et que gère
pour accueillir les emmerdeurs en gros
c'est ce qu'on comprend pas c'est les
yvelines one en aura il y aura deux noms
oui malheureusement il y en a aucun qui
soit aussi culotté cuit quand alors dans
les gens quittaient y avait quelqu'un
qui t'a beaucoup pdc tel christophe
riboud qui malheureusement nous a
quittés et j'ai lu dernièrement dans la
presse que paul loup sulitzer elle est
aidée alors est-ce que c'est quelqu'un
qui a toujours eu beaucoup de [ __ ] est
ce que tu es nouveau nec de succès non
christophe reboosté un animiste et plus
que qu'un parrain de l'association que
quelqu'un qui nous aidaient c'était bon
c'était un pote
vrai
il ya des gens qui nous aident bon là il
ya un certain nombre de gens qui peut
être après des missions aussi mieux
compris que
notre message il n'était pas politique
au sens partisan que c'était un message
assez clairement passé ouais je crois
que c'est important c'est un message à
la fois morale et réalisme du leader la
soul in their va il fait partie ces gens
là
c'est bien d'abord les soit parce que
c'est elle qui à leur sens de douala
parce que c'était aussi nettement je
prends pour un certain nombre de gens
que bon un conseiller financier
quelqu'un qui est un apôtre de l'argent
bien fait et vite fait et aussi un sens
de la morale du respect pour les autres
un sens de la dignité de ceux qui n'ont
pas forcément réussi comme lui et qui
qui qui croient que la société de demain
n'a de sens que s'il y adonnent
l'égalité des chances à tous styles et
ça ça moi je le crois
j'ai senti mon nom d'ailleurs paul loup
sulitzer il n'a pas dit quand il est
venu y compris hors enfin dans une
émission pour témoigner de son soutien
soit raciste mais lui de lui-même il est
d'origine immigrée mais c'est ce que
c'est que pas être compris et ce que
c'est que d'avoir à se battre pour se
faire reconnaître
alors ce soir je voudrais seulement de
poser des questions sur l'actualité je
pense qu'on aura l'occasion à noël de
faire toucher nos missions avec toi
enfin tous les cas je le souhaite
europe 1 c'est quoi cette histoire est
ce que c'est parce que
repas a besoin d'avoir des stars sur son
antenne est ce que c'est parce que tu es
mon argent et dans d'autres formats
moins qu'avant est ce que c'est parce
que tu es plein d'argent est ce que
c'est parce que tu as envie de s'amuser
à faire de la radio
je dois tu abuses et non non c'est vrai
ça m'amuse ça me plaît c'est un outil
qui a beaucoup de souplesse et
d'ailleurs l'idée de l'émission qui
s'appelle surprise donc c'est que
d'abord il n'ya pas une régularité
obligatoires voilà on dit que c'est
mauvais mais moi j'ai envie de faire la
démonstration fait face à hull pour
talence et à la botte peut-être mais qui
ont lieu par ge et quand on a quelque
chose à dire et que on a des vraies
informations apportées que on a des gens
intéressants à faire connaître que ce
soient des stars ou ce soir des inconnus
mais à qui on doit tirer son chapeau ou
à qui on doit donner la parole pour les
aider et donc l'émission sera deux fois
ou trois fois par mois
et puis en dehors de cette émission
surprise oncle dimanche matin de 11h à
12h et ni deux j'ai une collaboration
plus générale avec jean pierre elkabbach
ses directeurs d'organes kaddache os et
personnages assez étonnant lui aussi
d'avoir c'est un homme libre indépendant
il m'a fait la proposition donc de
d'utiliser d'une certaine façon cet
outil qui est la radio en portant mon
regard un mois sur la société avec mes
passions mes coups de colère mais aussi
avec peut-être des choses que les gens
ça moi on aime bien rire on est bien
l'humour parce que j'aime bien c'est
eddie murphy c'est woody allen ces gens
qui sont capables de prendre avec
dérision le malheur qu'on essaye de de
l'enfer retombées sur les épaules et
dans l'émission et à jean benguigui un
certain nombre d'amis comique qui
viennent avec nous parce que bon on peut
avoir des idées sans pour autant en
pleurer toute la journée à trier la
première ça s'est passé comment bien ça
a été un peu cafouillé du point de vue
de la théorie mais prenez en soin mais
l'important c'est que il y avait une
grande amitié dans le studio une grande
émotion
je crois qu'on a aussi montré des choses
qui existent qui sont sont plus
supportables dans la france
d'aujourd'hui on a montré comment si on
veut acheter un chien raciste basse est
possible de téléphoner à quasiment
n'importe quel jeune il en disant je
veux des copains de l'équipe jean
benguigui qui est comédien qui s'est mis
dans le rôle du chauffeur de taxi qui
cherchent un chien raciste et on a fait
déjà plusieurs thoniers on a trouvé à
chaque fois un chez racine on l on
appelle ça une dépense et quand la
prochaine
ça s'est déjà passé la première c'est le
18 octobre 18 octobre merci à la
matraque pour être sûr de nourrir un t2
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou